the movie opens up with a middle-aged
man named Escalante driving his old car
to Garfield High School where he is set
to start his first day as a teacher
along the way he looks through the
window and Witnesses the vibrant sights
of the Latino Community with people
selling fruit on the road and bustling
about their daily chores some time later
upon arriving at the school Escalante
walks up to the reception and receives
some bad news despite being hired as a
computer teacher the receptionist
informs him that he has been appointed
as a mathematics teacher instead when he
asks the authorities about this apparent
mistake he is informed that there are no
computers in the school and so he should
quietly do his assigned Duty having no
other options he reluctantly agrees
later as Escalante begins to navigate
his new role he meets Miss Raquel Ortega
the head of the math department who
accompanies him to his class
unfortunately when Escalante enters the
class the students appear to be
rebellious and disruptive and they argue
that math is not a valuable subject for
them to learn I don't need a long
division to know that I'm high right now
Escalon tries his best to get them under
control but to no avail to make matters
worse a false Bell ranks causing the
students to scatter outside the
classroom Escalante later discovers that
some students had broken the Bell to
make it ring randomly at the end of the
day after the classes end Escalante
returns to his car only to discover that
the window has been shattered and the
radio is missing feeling frustrated
about his first day at work he returned
home angrily later he spots his neighbor
Joe while taking out the trash and they
engage in a brief conversation from it
we get to know that Escalante used to
work at a computer company with a higher
salary before he decided to join the
school as a teacher his motivation for
the career change was to teach and help
Latino students get better marks on the
following day Escalante makes a dramatic
entrance to the classroom dressed in an
unusual butcher outfit and carrying a
bag of apples he has a creative idea to
teach the students about fractions and
proportions by cutting the apples into
different portions and distributing them
equally surprisingly the plan works and
the students are immediately engaged and
respond positively to the activity
laughing and learning at the same time
however a student with a rebellious
attitude disrupts the class by giving
Escalante the middle finger punch this
into your calculator Escalante despite
the disrespectful Behavior he remains
composed and calmly addresses the
situation he even teaches the unruly
student the multiples of nine by using
using his fingers in the next scene
Escalante's creativity and dedication to
his students are on full display as he
takes an Innovative approach to connect
with the unruly students he recognizes
that a personalized approach is
necessary to capture their attention and
convey the value of math education
Escalante engages with each student
individually weaving in stories of
Latino history and demonstrating how
math can open up a world of
possibilities he emphasizes the
importance of education and how it can
help individuals rise above their
circumstances with honesty and sincerity
Escalante explains that being illiterate
can limit one's career options to
pumping gas or selling Fried Chicken
while math skills can lead to Greater
opportunities and success to Escalante's
good luck the students respond
positively showing greater focus and
engagement in the classroom after the
class Escalante heads to the staff room
to attend a meeting with other teachers
where principal Molina reveals that the
school's accreditation is in danger due
to the poor performance of the students
the head of the math department Ortega
admits that despite their efforts the
teachers have been unable to raise the
student's scores this is when Escalante
boldly steps forward and declares that
he can improve the scores using his
unique teaching methods to demonstrate
his point the next day he quickly
subjects the students to a quiz contest
despite their reluctance to take part in
it Escalante encourages them to see math
as a tool for fighting against poverty
and racism as Escalante walks down the
hallway after class A student named
Angel approaches him seeking help he
confesses that he is unable to study due
to peer pressure and requests some books
to study at home acknowledging Angel's
desire to learn Escalante borrow some
books from the library Forum hoping to
help him succeed in his studies however
not all students are equally motivated
and one such student is Lupe who refuses
to submit her homework and even declines
to take the quiz as a punishment
Escalante brings her to the front of the
class and everyone laughs at her causing
her to feel humiliated this makes
Escalante feel bad but he also
understands that peer pressure and
embarrassment are powerful tools to
bring unruly and disobedient students
back on track in the next scene where
shown the harsh reality of Latino
students lives outside of the classroom
Angel struggles to balance his studies
with taking care of his sick grandmother
while Lupe has to look after her younger
siblings as her parents are always busy
with work the pressure of supporting
their families ways heavily on these
students and the consequences are severe
Anna a talented student has to drop out
of school to help run her family's
struggling restaurant sacrificing her
own education for the sake of her loved
ones one day Escalante and his wife
Fabiola pay a visit to Anna's family
restaurant and enjoy a meal together as
they chat Anna introduces Escalante to
her father and the conversation shifts
to education Escalante requests and his
father let her continue her studies but
he dismisses the idea citing the common
belief that girls are more likely to
become pregnant before getting a degree
frustrated by the narrow-mindedness of
the situation Escalante becomes angry
and emphasizes that denying Anna and
education would be a tragic waste of her
potential the following day in class
Escalante challenges his students with a
difficult algebraic problem this puts
everyone in a tough spot and just as
they're about to give up Anna arrives at
the classroom door and confidently
solves the problem to her Delight all
the students are impressed by her
intelligence and they cheer for her in
excitement this is not how I remember
High School later Escalante arranges a
field trip to the computer company where
he previously worked he wants to show
them how math can be applied in the real
world and how it can be a tool for
Success during the visit Escalante
learns that his friend's daughter is
already studying calculus in high school
which inspires him to aim even higher
for his students so he sets a goal to
teach calculus to his class from the
following year forward it's rare for
schools in the area to do so but
Escalante has full confidence that his
students will get accustomed to it when
he proposes his idea to Molina he also
adds that he wants his students to pass
the advanced placement test to ensure
that they have a chance to get into
college After High School however
department head Ortega interrupts the
conversation and suggests that some
teachers may not be able to pass the
test themselves she even goes as far as
threatening to leave her position in the
department if Escalante's words are
heard over hers despite the challenges
the principal ultimately agrees with
Escalante's ideas recognizing the
potential for the students to achieve
greatness and protect the school's
reputation the following scene opens
with the new school year and Escalante
is seen handing out contracts to his
students outlining the requirements for
attending extra classes before and after
regular school hours he urges them to
get their parents signatures to confirm
their commitment the following day all
the students except for one return with
their signed contract this student is
hesitant to commit to his studies and
instead wants to work in a garage to
support his family however Escalante
deals with him personally and manages to
persuade him to take the educational
path by providing a motivational example
next we see that the students begin to
learn calculus at an impressive Pace
later at night during a family dinner
Fabiola raises concerns over her
husband's workload here we learned that
he has been working extra hours teaching
in schools and coaching English to
Immigrant seniors unfortunately the
excessive pressure takes a toll on
Escalante and he suffers a heart attack
in one of his English classes he is
rushed to the hospital where the doctors
advise him to take a month's rest with
the placement test just two weeks away
his absence becomes a major hurdle for
his students they feel disheartened and
worried as their hard work and
dedication might go in vain due to the
lack of guidance from their teacher to
make matters worse the principal
suggests a music teacher is a substitute
for Escalante leaving the students in a
very perilous state in the following
scene despite being advised to take a
month's rest Escalante returns to the
school after only a few days he is
adamant on helping his students prepare
for the upcoming educational testing
service or ETS even at the expense of
his health as expected under his
guidance the students Excel and all of
them pass the exam bringing great pride
and celebration to Garfield High School
principal Molina announces their
achievement in the assembly and the
students present Escalante with a gift
as a token of appreciation for his hard
work however their success in
celebration are short-lived as the ETS
accuses the students of cheating due to
their identical mistakes in the answers
two each es officers Dr Pearson and Dr
Ramirez come to the Garfield School to
inspect the answer sheets in the exam
location but find no evidence of
cheating frustrated they've turned their
attention to the students and gather
them in a room pressuring them to
confess to cheating in the meantime
Angel attempts to lighten the mood but
fails to convince the officers to drop
their suspicion of cheating as they
leave the room the students feel uneasy
knowing that their academic Integrity
has been called into question Escalante
tries to console them but he is also
disappointed and doesn't know how to
deal with the situation later Escalante
seeks Ed Ortega's opinion on the matter
hoping for some insight into what may
have led to the accusations however her
suggestion that the students may have
cheated to please him leaves him feeling
even more conflicted upset he heads to
the parking lot only to find that his
car has been stolen so he is forced to
walk all the way home lost in his
thoughts meanwhile it is revealed that
Escalante's car was stolen by none other
than his students they actually plan to
repair and modify it as a gesture of
gratitude towards him the man just had a
heart attack and you made him walk home
you idiots cool present exhibit after
pouring their hearts and souls into it
the students finally returned the car to
Escalante's house although shocked at
first he thanks them warmly and Promises
to not give up on them no matter what
the next day Escalante goes straight to
the ETS office and confronts Dr Pearson
and Dr Ramirez the two officials have
accused his students of cheating on
their advanced placement exams citing
similarities in their answers Escalante
demands proof arguing that the
similarities could be attributed to
their shared teacher and classroom
rather than cheating however Pearson
raises the possibility of the student's
Latino Origins being a factor in their
suspected cheating this Sparks an
intense discussion about racism and bias
with Escalante strongly objecting to
such insinuations unfortunately the
meeting doesn't come to a conclusion so
Escalante leaves the ETS office feeling
frustrated and angry but he is still not
going to give up so with the help of his
students he decides to challenge the
system they prepare themselves to retake
the exams determined to prove their
ability and defy the accusations against
them as the day of the re-exam
approaches Escalante takes it upon
himself to ensure his students are well
prepared for all the questions he spends
the entire evening before the exam
helping his students with Calculus
problems while simultaneously cooking
dinner at his house on the morning of
the exam the students gather in the hall
while Escalante anxiously waits in his
office soon the test begins and everyone
starts answering the questions with
confidence the questions are harder than
usual but the students are well prepared
thanks to their heroic teachers efforts
as Escalante anxiously waits for the
test results he receives news that the
school has finally received computers
filled with anticipation he rushes to
the principal's office as soon as he
hears him discussing the results over
the phone the Escalante's Delight he
finds out that all of his students have
passed the test with exemplary scores a
testament to their hard work and
Escalante's dedication to teaching the
movie ends with Escalante walking out of
the principal's room and a title card
stating that from 1982 to 1987 the
number of students passing the AP
Calculus test at Garfield High School
increased significantly going from just
18 to an impressive 87.
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching